as you can join we have a visual on Mars
brace for our injury engage artificial
intelligence support commencing circular
rotation crash investigation should
include the government's lead
investigator people need answers the
families need answers the people can
wait
good morning mission supervisor
Mackenzie Wilson
good morning RT I'm pleased to report
that all systems are nominal on the Mars
Lander craft let's see if we could find
out what happened let's give it a shot
launch countdown initiated why are we
launching five hours early who
authorized it I did our T's taking lead
on the crash investigation you are
living in his world now we created AI to
help us not to beat us never needs to be
smart not human
I have an origin unknown
what are we looking at Aqueduct or you
artificial intelligence or alien
intelligence be prepared for every
possibility warning
unidentified satellite detected firing
please tell me I'm hallucinating
sorry McKenzie I mission controller a we
friends who knows what is capable of
[Music]
this is an international incident no no
no you have to stop them
the human race must adapt or perish
it's everything we were warned about
[Music]
you